I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, Angela. Hi there, lady. Hi, everyone. Hi. Today we're going to talk about the cover up. It is season six, episode 24, written by Jean Stupnitzky and Lee Eisenberg. We love them and directed by our very own, Rainn Wilson. Rainn! Here is your summary. Michael becomes convinced that Donna, remember the manager from Sid and Dexter, who bought all the printers
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一同出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来专属于你的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。嗨，安吉拉。你好呀，女士。大家好。嗨。今天我们要聊的是“掩盖”。这是第六季第二十四集，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧。我们很喜欢他们，导演则是我们亲爱的雷恩·威尔逊。雷恩！这是你的剧情梗概。迈克尔开始确信唐娜——还记得西德和德克斯特那位买下所有打印机的经理吗？
last week. How many we don't know. How many she needs, we're not sure. But it turns out Michael was right. She was giving signals they are full on dating. But today he's going to become convinced that Donna is cheating on him. Yes. And he's going to ask Dwight to find out the truth. I mean, this is Dwight Superbowl. He's so excited. He's so excited. He gets to go undercover. I mean, he like dives across a table in the break room when he gets the news. That wasn't even in the script. I wanted to see. I looked it up in the shooting draft. It just says Dwight sprints out. But that table move, that was Rainn. I believe it. Well, meanwhile, Darryl gets delayed revenge on Andy for a past issue that
上周买的。具体多少我们不知道。需要多少我们也不太清楚。但事实证明迈克尔是对的。她一直在释放信号，他们正在全面交往。但今天他将开始确信唐娜在背着他偷人。没错。而且他要让德怀特去查明真相。我的意思是，这简直是德怀特的超级碗。他太激动了。他兴奋极了。他得以去卧底。我是说，当他听到这个消息时，他像那样扑过休息室的桌子。那甚至都不在剧本里。我想看。我在拍摄初稿里查过。上面只写着德怀特冲出去。但那个扑桌子的动作，那是雷恩即兴发挥的。我相信。好吧，与此同时，达里尔就过去的一件事对安迪进行了一场迟来的报复。
upset him. And he does this by making him think that Gabe is going to fire him for revealing the truth about the faulty Sabre printers. Turns out, sometimes they catch on fire. Turns out there might be something really happening. Fast fact number one is that Rainn Wilson directed this episode. Rainn directed three episodes of The Office. And this was his first. We reached out to Rainn. And he sent in some audio clips, which he recorded while driving in traffic. And you can hear at the end, it's like accident up ahead. Rainn, maybe he stopped talking to us. All right, here is what Rainn had to say about directing. Hello there, Office ladies. It's me, your old pal Rainn. So I understand you're doing
让他心烦意乱的那件事。他的做法是让安迪以为盖布要因为他泄露了萨博打印机有缺陷的真相而把他解雇。事实证明，有时候它们真的会着火。事实证明，可能真的有这么一回事。第一条趣味冷知识是，雷恩·威尔逊执导了这一集。雷恩一共执导了三集《办公室》。而这是他的第一集。我们联系了雷恩。他发来了一些音频剪辑，那是他在堵车时录的。你可以在最后听到，听起来像前面发生了车祸。雷恩，也许他不跟我们说话了。好吧，以下是雷恩对当导演的看法。大家好，办公室女郎们。是我，你们的老朋友雷恩。所以我听说你们正在聊
the cover up in this week's episode. How exciting. Dwight unleashed as a private detective to investigate Donna. A lot of great scenes in the gym with that great ending of Dwight leading the cycling spin class. A lot of people ask about what it's like to act in the show while you're directing. You know, the fortunate thing is that we, we were so familiar with the show at that point, it would have been impossible in the first three seasons. Impossible. You know, we're still kind of learning the landscape and still discovering stuff about our characters and, you know, getting used to how everything's going. But by season six, here we are four or five, six, we get the show, we get how it's shot, where to place
本周的剧集“掩盖”。太令人兴奋了。德怀特变身私家侦探去调查唐娜。健身房里有很多精彩的场景，以德怀特带领动感单车课作为高潮结尾。很多人问，一边演戏一边导演这部剧是什么感觉。你知道，幸运的是，我们，我们当时对这部剧太熟悉了，如果在前三季里这是不可能的。不可能。你知道，我们当时还在摸索环境，还在不断发现我们角色的特质，你知道，还在适应一切的发展。但到了第六季，现在我们拍到了第四、五、六季，我们懂这部剧了，我们懂它是怎么拍的，镜头该放在哪里
cameras is a lot easier. There's always some scenes that are quite challenging and difficult to figure out how you're going to cover them in a unique and interesting way. The thing I always said about the directing of the office is like, the scripts are so good and the cast is so good and the camera crew is so good that you'll always get at least a B plus episode. So what the really good directors like Ken Quapas and Paul Feig and several others were able to do is like, take a B plus A minus episode and move it to an A. So you always want to just those little touches, the little flourishes, the little improvs, interesting ways to shoot things can kind of just raise the level a little bit. And that's kind of
这要容易得多。总有一些场景相当具有挑战性，很难想出该如何以独特而有趣的方式来拍摄它们。我关于《办公室》导演工作常说的一句话是，剧本太棒了，演员阵容太棒了，摄像组也太棒了，所以你至少总能拍出一集B+水准的节目。因此，真正优秀的导演，比如肯·夸帕斯、保罗·菲格和其他几位，他们所能做到的就是，把一集B+或A-的剧集提升到A级。所以你总是希望加入那些微小的触笔、小小的点缀、少许即兴创作、有趣的拍摄方式，从而把水准稍微提升那么一点点。而这差不多
always the goal as a director. I think Paul Lieberstein was an excellent director for the office. He really got that, captured a lot of subtlety in the show. And what an amazing bounty for all of us to kind of flex our directing muscles and get an opportunity to direct. I learned so much. You know, it keeps coming up again and again with our directors, whether established or new, how great our crew and how supportive our crew was. And what a well oiled machine we were at this point. I mean, Rain's really right. Yeah. And we also really knew our characters.
一直作为导演的目标。我认为保罗·利伯斯坦是《办公室》的一位优秀导演。他真正理解并捕捉到了剧中大量的微妙之处。对我们所有能够施展导演才华、获得执导机会的人来说，这简直是一笔惊人的财富。我学到了太多。我们的导演们，无论是老牌的还是新晋的，不断地提起并重复的一点是，我们的剧组有多么出色，我们的剧组有多么支持我们。而且在这一点上，我们是一台运转良好的机器。我是说，雷恩真的说得对。是的。而且我们也确实很了解我们的角色。
Well, I also asked Rain, what was challenging about directing? Here's what he had to say. It was challenging because, you know, you're working with your castmates and these are people that know you as an actor. So you have to be quite gentle and diplomatic in your notes and in your thoughts because you're working with your family, you know, you're not all of a sudden horse and wells, the boss, you're a collaborator offering a point of view on directing the episode. But I found it really fun to kind of put on the director hat and then put on the Dwight hat. But like I said, you can only do that if you've been doing it for many, many years and feel really comfortable in your character, you're just
好吧，我还问了雷恩，当导演有什么挑战性。他是这么说的。这很有挑战性，你知道的，因为你在和你的演员同伴合作，而这些人是以演员身份认识你的。所以你在提意见和想法时必须相当温和和外交，因为你是在和你的家人合作，你知道的，你并非突然间就成了霍斯和韦尔斯那样的老板，你只是一个就如何导演这一集提出看法的合作者。但我发现，戴上导演帽然后再戴上德怀特帽，这种感觉真的很有趣。但就像我说的，只有当你做了很多很多年、对自己的角色感到非常自在时，你才能做到这一点，你才能
able to slip on your character clothes and personality and point of view and jump right in. Otherwise, it would have been extremely difficult. And we got a lot of support as actors moving into the director's chair. It's a delightful episode towards the end of season six and had a blast. And I'm glad you guys are digging into it. All right, all for now. Love you guys. Bye. I could imagine it would be really weird to direct people you've been hanging out with for six years. Oh, for sure. But I loved this quote from what Rain said. He said he saw himself as a collaborator offering a point of view. I have to say, I feel like that encapsulates
轻松套上角色的衣服、个性和观点，然后直接入戏。否则，这将极其困难。而且作为从演员转型为导演的人，我们得到了很多支持。这是第六季临近结束时令人愉快的一集，大家玩得很开心。很高兴你们能深入探讨它。好了，暂时就这些。爱你们，伙计们。拜拜。我可以想象，去导演那些你已经相处了六年的人，感觉一定非常诡异。哦，肯定的。但我很喜欢雷恩所说的那句话。他说他把自己看作是一个提供观点的合作者。我必须说，我觉得这完美概括了
the whole tone of our show. We were all collaborators with a point of view. And we had this safe place where we could share our point of view. Thank you, Rain, for sending in those audio clips. It was very generous of him because he just got back from Iceland. Yes, he literally just flew back from Iceland. Rain, you brave jet lag to talk to us. What he was doing in Iceland is a new television show called The Geography of Bliss. One grumps search for the happiest places in the world. I cannot wait. I cannot believe this job. How do you get this job? I mean, Jenna, how that is just like the coolest thing. He gets to travel all over and just be himself. Yeah, he gets to go to Iceland, Ghana, Japan, and more.
我们剧集的整体基调。我们都是带着各自观点的合作者。我们拥有这样一个安全的地方，可以分享我们的观点。谢谢雷恩发来这些音频剪辑。他太慷慨了，因为他刚从冰岛回来。是的，他 literalmente 刚刚从冰岛飞回来。雷恩，你为了跟我们聊天真是克服了严重的有时差反应。他在冰岛做的事是一个叫做《极乐地理学》的新电视节目。一个脾气暴躁的人寻找世界上最快乐的地方。我简直等不及了。我简直不敢相信这份工作。你怎么能得到这份工作？我是说，珍娜，这简直太酷了。他可以到处旅行，还能做他自己。是的，他可以去冰岛、加纳、日本以及更多地方。
And it says it's a six part travel series where he will try to discover how changing your location and perspective can change your life. This is the greatest job of all time. It's so awesome, Rain. Why didn't we think of this? Rain, we cannot wait to watch. Can me and you do The Geography of Bliss part two to ladies who love factories? Yes. Can we do that? Can it just be ladies who love factories? We'll just travel the United States. We don't even have to go far. I like this show. I really like it. Call us anyone who makes shows. Anybody. All right. And fast fact number two, this show centers around Michael's suspicion that Donna is cheating on him. So guess what I Googled. Wait. Sign someone's
上面说这是一个六集的旅行系列节目，他将在其中试图发现，改变你的地点和视角如何能改变你的生活。这是史上最棒的工作。太棒了，雷恩。我们怎么没想到这个？雷恩，我们等不及要看了。我和你可以做《极乐地理学》第二季——“热爱工厂的女人们”吗？可以吗？能只叫“热爱工厂的女人们”吗？我们就环游美国。甚至都不用去太远。我喜欢这个节目。我真的很喜欢。任何做节目的人，给我们打电话。任何人。好吧，第二条趣味冷知识，本节目的核心是迈克尔怀疑唐娜在背着他偷人。所以你们猜我谷歌了什么。等一下。某人出轨的迹象。
cheating. Oh my gosh. Yes. Really? Literally. Sign someone is cheating. Let's hear them. Did you look at my piece of paper? I did not. I just listen. I'm getting better at guessing your deep dives. All right. Well, according to psychology today, there are 10 signs that your spouse or significant other is cheating. Number one. Number one. What is it? One is crazy. What? Improved appearance. Oh, they care now. Yeah. Are they getting gussied up each day in a new way that they haven't before? Did they put the sweatpants aside? Number two, are they having secretive phone or computer use? You know, like do they sneak away to use their phone when maybe they didn't before? Stepping outside to take a call kind
哦天哪。是的。真的吗？字面意思。某人出轨的迹象。我们听听看。你看我的纸条了吗？我没有。我只是听着。我猜你深度挖掘的能力越来越强了。好吧，根据《今日心理学》的说法，你的配偶或另一半出轨有十个迹象。第一条。第一条。是什么？第一条是疯狂。什么？外表焕然一新。哦，他们现在开始注重外表了。对啊。他们是不是每天都以一种以前没有过的新方式把自己打扮得漂漂亮亮的？他们把运动裤放一边了吗？第二条，他们是否有偷偷摸摸使用手机或电脑的行为？你知道的，比如他们会不会在以前可能不会的时候偷偷走开去用手机？
of thing. Exactly, lady. Exactly. I'm feeling very mom detective right now. Yeah. We should use this list if we have a case like this. Oh, yeah. For our show. A checklist. Yeah. We'll check them off. Check it off. All right. Number three. Are there periods of time when your significant other is unreachable? That would be part of our interview. Turn the phone off. Not answering. I don't know why you're cracking me up so much. All right. Number four. This one feels like a tough one. Is there significantly more, significantly less or different sex in your relationship? Huh. Like, I kind of get it. If you're married, you've got a bit of a sex routine at a certain point. Yeah. You know, you've got your favorite
比如走到外面去接电话那种。完全正确，女士。完全正确。我现在觉得自己就像个妈妈侦探。对啊。如果我们遇到这样的案子，我们就该用这个清单。哦，对。为了我们的节目。一个核对清单。对。我们把它们勾掉。勾掉。好吧。第三条。有没有一段时间你的另一半是联系不上的？那将是我们访谈的一部分。关掉手机。不接电话。我不知道为什么你让我觉得这么搞笑。好吧。第四条。这条感觉有点难。你们的关系中，性生活是不是明显增多、明显减少或者有所不同？
moves, the old standbys, the ones that you know are going to get you there. Also, you know your windows of opportunity. Right. Especially if you have kids. Is there sudden spontaneity? Are they trying new moves? Yeah. Where'd they get those moves? Right. Or are they not even interested at all? Not at all. I don't know what. It's cracking me up. All right. We're only on number five. Oh gosh. Is there hostility toward you and the relationship all of a sudden? Distain. Are they annoyed? Yeah. Number six. Do they have an altered schedule? Number seven. Okay. Do friends suddenly seem uncomfortable around you? And this is important because as a couple, like your friends or just you personally, they say it's because the betrayed
哈。就像，我有点懂。如果你结婚了，在某个节点上你们会有一定的性生活常规。对啊。你知道的，你有你最喜欢的招式，那些老牌招式，那些你知道能帮你达到高潮的招式。此外，你知道你的机会窗口。对吧。特别是如果你有孩子的话。有没有突然出现的自发性？他们是在尝试新招式吗？对啊。他们从哪学来这些招式的？对吧。或者他们根本就没兴趣？完全没有。我不知道怎么回事。这把我逗乐了。好吧。我们才进行到第五条。哦天哪。突然之间，他们对你和这段关系充满敌意吗？轻蔑。他们觉得烦吗？对啊。第六条。他们的日程表改变了吗？第七条。
partner is almost always the last to know. So people know. And so then they like avoid eye contact with you or they're real shifty. Yeah. Number eight. Are there any unexplained expenses? Mm-hmm. Travel. This is your character for mom detectives. Okay. Like a hundred percent. You are this person. Okay. I will sit with the client and I will ask these questions and you will say these things. Just one word. Yep. Yep. All right. Here on the next one. Okay. Let's pretend we have a client. Okay. Client is sitting next to you. Yeah. I'm sitting across. All right. Okay. Ma'am. Mm-hmm. Has the emotional intimacy faded? Nothing happening in the sack. That's not one word. That's all right. It doesn't have to be one word. I,
好吧。朋友们突然在你面前显得不自在吗？这很重要，因为作为伴侣，比如你们的朋友或者仅仅是你个人，他们说这是因为被背叛的伴侣几乎总是最后一个知道的。所以大家其实都知道。然后他们就会避开你的目光，或者显得鬼鬼祟祟的。对啊。第八条。有没有任何无法解释的开销？嗯哼。旅行。这就是你扮演妈妈侦探时的角色。好吧。百分之百。你就是这个人。好吧。我会和客户坐在一起，我会问这些问题，而你会说这些话。就一个词。对吧。对吧。好吧。接着看下一条。好吧。假装我们有一个客户。好吧。客户正坐在你旁边。对啊。我坐在对面。好吧。
you know what I realized? My job is like, I think I'm a translator. You're translating my very clear question. Yeah. Do another one. This is the last one. Okay. Number 10. Sign that someone is cheating. Has your partner been deflecting or avoiding being questioned about cheating? Like if you say, hey, where were you last night? Were you with someone else? Where were you? Exactly. What? That might mean they're cheating. There you go, guys. I think this is our first episode of mom detectives. Someone is having an affair. We think maybe. Who knows? That couple down the street on the left, the house with the green door, we're going to get to the bottom of it. I like the idea that neither of them
好吧。女士。嗯哼。情感上的亲密感是不是褪色了？床上什么都没发生。那不是一个词。没关系。不一定非得是一个词。我，你知道我意识到什么吗？我的工作就像是，我觉得我是一个翻译。你在翻译我非常清晰的问题。对啊。再来一个。这是最后一个。好吧。第十条。某人出轨的迹象。你的伴侣是否一直在转移话题，或者回避关于出轨的质问？就像如果你说，嘿，你昨晚去哪了？你跟别人在一起吗？你到底去哪了？完全正确。什么？那可能意味着他们在出轨。就是这样，伙计们。我想这是我们的第一集妈妈侦探。有人有婚外情。我们觉得可能吧。谁知道呢？
came to us either. There's no client. No, no. It's just our own snooping. We've seen a new car parked out front. What's that about? Yeah. Going to run those plates. Wow. We don't have any contact. We'll Google it. All right. Fast fact number three is straight from our mailbag. Oh, I love our mailbag. I know. I hadn't been in the general folder for a while and I took a peek and here are two that I found delightful. First up, Stephanie from Sydney, Australia said, did you ladies know that there is a song by Post Malone called Candy Paint and in the lyrics, they say, I love paper like a Michael Scott. What? I just thought it was a fun thing for you guys to know about and to hear the office has even
街那头左手边的那对夫妇，绿门的那栋房子，我们要查个水落石出。我喜欢这种设定，他们两个其实都没有来找我们。没有客户。不，不。这纯粹是我们自己的窥探。我们看到一辆新车停在门前。那是怎么回事？对啊。要去查查车牌。哇。我们没有任何联系方式。我们去谷歌一下。好吧。第三条趣味冷知识直接来自我们的信箱。哦，我爱我们的信箱。我知道。我有一段时间没看综合文件夹了，我偷看了一眼，发现了这两封让我觉得很有趣的信。首先，来自澳大利亚悉尼的斯蒂芬妮说，女士们，你们知道吗，有一首Post Malone的歌叫《糖果漆》，歌词里唱道，我爱钱如迈克尔·斯科特。
made it into some of the best known songs of this generation. Here's an audio clip. I love it. Thank you so much, Stephanie for telling us about that. Also, Tommy from Salt Lake City, Utah and Hannah from Seattle, Washington wrote in to say, have you guys heard the song Netflix trip by AJR? It is a song where the singer outlines the major events of his life and how the office tied in and influenced all of them. It finished by saying that so much of who he is as a person is contained in the office and it is more than just a show to so many of us. Here is a clip. So it's this really sweet song and he just goes through all of these different aspects
什么？我只是觉得这对你们来说是一件有趣的事，而且听说《办公室》甚至已经进入了这一代人最著名的歌曲中，这让你们了解一下。这里有一段音频。我太喜欢了。非常感谢斯蒂芬妮告诉我们这件事。另外，来自犹他州盐湖城的汤米和来自华盛顿州西雅图的汉娜写信来说，你们听过AJR的歌《网飞之旅》吗？这是一首歌，歌手在其中概述了他生活中的重大事件，以及《办公室》是如何将所有这些串联并影响它们的。最后他说，他作为个人的很大一部分都包含在《办公室》里，对我们中的许多人来说，它不仅仅是一部剧。这里有一个片段。所以这是一首非常甜蜜的歌，他讲述了他生活中的所有这些不同方面
of his life and major milestones, his first crush, but it's like he's watching the office at the same time and so many of his personal moments are tied into his favorite moments on the show. That's just so cool. I know. I can't believe we're on a show that keeps finding a home in people's hearts like that. I know it's in that Billie Eilish song, which is so cool. Yeah, where she actually sampled parts of Threat Level Midnight, which we're going to get to next season. We're almost there, season seven. Oh my gosh, Billie Eilish, will you come on our show for Threat Level Midnight? Billie Eilish, my daughter asks me once a week if we are going to have you on office ladies for Threat Level Midnight and she has asked
以及重要的里程碑，他的第一次暗恋，但这就像他同时在看《办公室》一样，他的许多个人高光时刻都与他在剧中喜爱的时刻交织在一起。这实在是太酷了。我知道。我简直不敢相信我们参演了一部能在人们心中这样找到归宿的剧。我知道它出现在碧梨的那首歌里，太酷了。是的，她甚至采样了《威胁级午夜》的片段，我们下一季就会讲到。我们快到了，第七季。哦天哪，碧梨，你能来我们的节目聊聊《威胁级午夜》吗？碧梨，我女儿每周都问我一次，我们什么时候能在《办公室女郎》节目里请到你来聊《威胁级午夜》，她还问我
me if she can hide in the background of that Zoom so that she can see you. Awww. Every week, she asks. Well, I met Billie and she's a sweetheart. She's the loveliest. Billie, come on, bye. We'll have to reach out. And now for a DVD box set moment. Oh, I made it sound so official. For those of you with the DVD box set of the office, you will know that the episode, The Cover Up, starts the very last disc of the season. Okay. And since it's the last disc, it has some really fun bonus features I thought I would share. In addition to the usual deleted scenes for the last three episodes, which are The Cover Up, The Chump, and The Whistleblower, it has 23 minutes and 41 seconds worth of bloopers from season six. Oh, all the season
她能不能藏在那个Zoom画面的背景里，这样她就能看到你了。噢。她每周都问。嗯，我见过碧梨，她是个甜心。她可爱极了。碧梨，来吧，拜拜。我们得去联系她。现在是DVD套装时刻。哦，我把它说得这么官方。对于那些拥有《办公室》DVD套装的人来说，你们会知道“掩盖”这一集是本季的最后一张光盘。好吧。既然它是最后一张光盘，里面有一些非常有趣的额外花絮，我想和大家分享一下。除了最后三集的常规删减片段（也就是“掩盖”、“替罪羊”和“告密者”）之外，它还包含了23分41秒的第六季幕后花絮。哦，第六季所有的花絮都在上面吗？是的。
six bloopers are on there? Yes. It was really fun to watch them. It also has a digital short called Wait For It? Drumroll, Please. Do you just ask for the drumroll? I know. I don't know how long the drumroll calls. Like, when does the drumroll end? Ding! Okay, it ended. It's called The Podcast. Oh, yeah. We did a digital short called The Podcast. It is about Gabe on a quest to find a way onto the Saber website. He wants to be on the Saber website and he decides to do a podcast. It features Brian Baumgartner, Creed Bratton, Kate Flannery, Mindy Kaling, Ellie Kemper, Oscar Nunez, Zach Woods, and myself. It's crazy. I watched the whole thing and I had completely forgotten that we did this digital
看它们真的很有趣。它还有一个数字短片叫作……等一下？请敲鼓。你刚才是要求敲鼓吗？我知道。我不知道敲鼓要持续多久。比如，敲鼓什么时候结束？叮！好吧，结束了。它叫作《播客》。哦，对。我们拍了一个叫作《播客》的数字短片。讲的是盖布为了找一条上萨博网站的路而进行的一番探索。他想上萨博网站，于是他决定做一个播客。参演的有布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳、克里德·布拉顿、凯特·弗兰纳里、敏迪·卡灵、埃莉·肯珀、奥斯卡·努涅斯、扎克·伍兹和我自己。这太疯狂了。我把整段都看了一遍，而我完全忘了我们拍过这个数字短片。
short. Should we break down some of these things like the digital short, the podcast, and the web episodes sometime? I think we should. It's like a really fun bonus episode because they're good. Yeah. Also, this disc has all of the office promos for the Olympics in Canada. One that I had not seen. It's called Dwight's Tribute to Canada. Oh, no. You have to hear it. I can't believe Rain learned this. The Olympics are in Vancouver. Is that British Columbia? Well, Pam, there's really only a few things you need to know about Canada. There's Newfoundland and Labrador, Saskatchewan, Ontario, Quebec, Alberta, Manitoba, New Brunswick, and Nova Scotia. Prince Edward Island's very small, but British Columbia tops them all.
我们是不是应该找个时间剖析一下其中一些内容，比如数字短片《播客》和网络剧集？我觉得我们应该这么做。这就像是一集非常有趣的额外番外，因为它们真的很棒。是的。另外，这张光盘上还有所有关于加拿大奥运会的《办公室》宣传片。其中有一个我没看过。它叫作《德怀特对加拿大的致敬》。哦，不。你们得听听看。我简直不敢相信雷恩背下了这个。奥运会在温哥华举行。那是英属哥伦比亚省吗？嗯，帕姆，关于加拿大你其实只需要知道几件事。有纽芬兰与拉布拉多、萨斯喀彻温、安大略、魁北克、艾伯塔、马尼托巴、新不伦瑞克和新斯科舍。爱德华王子岛非常小，但英属哥伦比亚拔得头筹。
And that's where Vancouver is. But before I finish up my story, you should know the territories that are only three so well be quick. You come Northwestern on of it. If you want to have a Baldur's Saskatoon in Montreal and if you want to pack your sacks, we'll be going off to Halifax. And if you're looking for a wife, be sure to visit Yellowknife. Natural Resources! Perennial Geraniums, Nickel Think Uranium are filling up my cradium, the exports that they boast. Keep going. No, please. We're good. Thank you. Isn't that amazing? I remember shooting that. He had to learn that whole song. That's pretty amazing. I thought it was amazing. The last bonus feature on this disc is an episode from Parks and Rec that
那就是温哥华所在的地方。但在我讲完故事之前，你应该知道领地只有三个，所以很快就会讲完。西北领地、努纳武特。如果你想吃萨斯卡通的萨斯喀彻温浆果，那就去蒙特利尔；如果你想收拾行囊，我们就去哈利法克斯。如果你在寻找妻子，务必去访问黄刀镇。自然资源！多年生天竺葵，镍和铀充满我的颅骨，他们夸耀的出口。继续。不，请。我们好了。谢谢。是不是太神奇了？我还记得拍摄那段的情景。他得把整首歌都学会。这相当了不起。我觉得太惊人了。这张光盘上的最后一个彩蛋是一集《公园与游憩》，
was written by Dan Gore and directed by Greg Daniels called Hunting Trip. Oh, that's so cool. So there you have it. Let's take a break because when we come back, Pam and Jim are going to be talking using some pins. Yeah, some pin talk. Well, we are back. It looks like Pam is purposefully tapping on her computer mouse and then Jim is kind of clicking his pin and Dwight is getting annoyed. But wait a second. He starts picking up on something. That's right. Are Pam and Jim communicating in Morse code? Dwight thinks so. Pam and Jim are like, that's ridiculous. But then they have a super cute talking head. They do. And I just want to say that Jim stills one of Pam's moves. What's that? He starts
由丹·戈尔编剧、格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导，名为《狩猎之旅》。哦，太酷了。好了，就是这样。我们休息一下，因为等我们回来，帕姆和吉姆要开始用大头针交流了。是的，一些大头针谈话。好了，我们回来了。看起来帕姆在故意敲击她的电脑鼠标，然后吉姆在咔哒咔哒地按他的大头针，德怀特开始觉得烦了。但等一下。他开始察觉到什么了。没错。帕姆和吉姆在用摩斯密码交流吗？德怀特是这么认为的。帕姆和吉姆觉得，这太荒谬了。但随后他们有了一段超级可爱的对镜独白。他们确实有。而且我只想说，吉姆偷了帕姆的一个招牌动作。是什么？他以“对啊”开头。
with yup. It turns out that with their limited time and resources, they did hire a nanny so that they could take a course on speaking in Morse code just to drive Dwight crazy. It's exactly what they did. Lady, we got so much mail about this cold open and it sent me down a number of roads. Let's start with the fan mail flurry. That's right. Katie A. from Nashville, Tennessee, Cammie D. from Richmond, Virginia, and many others would like to know, did John and Jenna have to learn Morse code for the cold open? And if so, what were you guys saying? Well, here's what I'll tell you. Lindsay G. from Texas has the answer. Okay. Lindsay says, my husband Jason is a licensed amateur radio operator.
原来，由于时间和资源有限，他们确实雇了一个保姆，这样他们就可以去上一个学习摩斯密码的课程，纯粹是为了把德怀特逼疯。他们就是这么干的。女士，我们收到了关于这个冷开场的巨量邮件，这把我带向了许多不同的方向。让我们从粉丝邮件风暴开始吧。没错。来自田纳西州纳什维尔的凯蒂·A、来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的卡米·D以及许多其他人想知道，约翰和珍娜为了这个冷开场必须学习摩斯密码吗？如果是的话，你们俩当时在说什么？好吧，这就是我要告诉你们的。来自得克萨斯州的林赛·G知道答案。好吧。林赛说，我丈夫杰森是一名持证业余无线电操作员。
And when I introduced him to the office, I showed him this episode. Jason let me know that Pam and Jim are saying random letters and characters, but nothing that matches the actual script. Yes, Lindsay, Jason, you are right. We did not learn anything for this scene. We randomly clicked our pen. And if you look at the script, it doesn't even tell us how much to click our pen. It just says we're clicking. Right. Just click away. This is like that moment when I took my dad to see Armageddon. Uh-huh. Starts out, they're drilling engineers. And my dad just sat there and kept going, never happened. That never happened. Yeah, that's right. Never happened. Lindsay went on to say, some radio info for you. My husband has had his license since he was 11 and learned from
当我向他介绍《办公室》时，我给他看了这一集。杰森告诉我，帕姆和吉姆说的是随机的字母和字符，但没有一个符合实际的剧本。是的，林赛，杰森，你们是对的。我们为这个场景什么都没学。我们只是随心所欲地按动大头针。如果你看剧本，它甚至没有告诉我们按多少次大头针。上面只写着我们在按。对吧。随便按呗。这就像当年我带我爸去看《绝世天劫》一样。嗯哼。一开始，他们是钻井工程师。然后我爸就坐在那里不停地说，这绝不可能发生。这绝不可能发生。对啊，没错。绝不可能发生。林赛接着说，给你们提供一些无线电知识。我丈夫从11岁起就有了执照，是跟他爸爸学的。
his dad. When he got his license in the US, it was required to pass the Morse code test. Today, it is not required to know Morse code to get your radio operator license. Yet he frequently uses Morse code in radio contests and knows it as well as he can speak English. Wow. She said, there are several Morse code and voice contests throughout the year. One of the biggest being Field Day, which happened every summer. Field Day is meant to be a practice run for radio operators in emergency situations. That's so cool. Very, very cool. All right. Next up from the mailbag about the cold open from Julia T. in Orange, California. Can we talk about the way John Krasinski says pen in the cold open? Julia, we can, but first I think we should give it a listen.
他在美国获得执照时，要求必须通过摩斯密码测试。而今天，要获得无线电操作员执照已经不需要懂摩斯密码了。然而，他经常在无线电比赛中使用摩斯密码，并且对它的熟悉程度就像说英语一样好。哇。她说，全美全年有几次摩斯密码和语音比赛。其中最大的一场是“野外日”，每年夏天举行。“野外日”旨在作为无线电操作员在紧急情况下的实操演练。太酷了。非常非常酷。好吧。来自信箱关于冷开场的下一封信来自加利福尼亚州奥兰治的茱莉亚·T。我们能聊聊约翰·卡拉辛斯基在冷开场里说“pen”（笔）的发音方式吗？茱莉亚，我们可以聊，但首先我觉得我们应该听一听。
We should. Jim, are you clicking a detonator? It's a pin. Well, and what do you think? Did you hear it? He says, pin. But he says more like pin, like instead of pen, he says, pin. Do you say, pin or pen? I say, pin. But that's when, you know, I'm sort of just letting myself be a little lazy with my accent. But if I try to think about it, I would say, pen, pen. Right? Am I saying it right? Pen. Pen. But I have to think about it. If I don't think about it, I just say, can I borrow your pen? Yeah. Yeah. He also says, D white. He says, D white and pin. Well, there's another thing he says too, but I'll bring it up later. All right. Finally, we got this fan question from Allen Jay in Salt Lake City, Utah. In the beginning of this episode, the pen that Jim is clicking is a Parker
我们应该听听。吉姆，你在按引爆器吗？这是一支笔。好吧，你们觉得呢？你听到了吗？他说的是，pin。但他说的更像是pin，比起pen，他说的是pin。你们说的是pin还是pen？我说的是pin。但那是当我，你知道的，对自己的口音稍微有点偷懒的时候。但如果我刻意去想，我会说，pen，pen。对吧？我发对了吗？Pen。Pen。但我必须去想。如果我不去想，我就会说，能借你的pen吗？对啊。对啊。他还说，D white。他说，D white和pin。好吧，他还说了另一件事，但我待会儿再提。好吧。最后，我们收到了来自犹他州盐湖城艾伦·J的粉丝提问。在这集的开头，吉姆按的那支笔是派克笔公司制造的派克灵动笔。
Jotter made by the Parker Pen Company. I've noticed this pen in several episodes of not only the office, but Parks and Rec, Brooklyn Nine-Nine and The Good Place, all of which Mike Shore has had his hand in. Are these pens used by Mike Shore personally or in all of his projects? Or is it just a random prop coincidence? Well, all of those shows are NBC shows. True. I emailed Mike Shore. What did he say? Can you imagine? I think we are so weird. Hey, Mike, do you have a signature pin on all of your shows? Thanks, K. Bye. Yes. I sent the fan question and he said, he does not know anything about this pen. But then he admitted, quote, my family owns 28.5% of Parker Pen Company and it's a total boondoggle product placement. He's kidding, of course.
我不仅在《办公室》的好几集里注意到这支笔，还在《公园与游憩》、《神烦警探》和《善地》里看到过，所有这些剧迈克尔·舒尔都参与过。这些笔是迈克尔·舒尔个人在所有项目中都在使用，还是这只是一个随机的道具巧合？好吧，所有这些节目都是NBC的节目。确实。我给迈克尔·舒尔发了电子邮件。他说了什么？你能想象吗？我觉得我们太怪了。嘿，迈克尔，你的所有节目里都有一支标志性的笔吗？谢谢，K。拜拜。是的。我把粉丝的提问发了过去，他说他根本不知道这支笔的事。但随后他承认，原话是，“我家族拥有派克笔公司28.5%的股份，这是一次彻头彻尾的无聊产品植入。”他当然是在开玩笑。
He is kidding. He is kidding. Well, I got a little curious about this Parker Jotter pen. They retail for about $12 each. I see. And here is where my curiosity led me. There is a podcast called The Pen Addict. Really? Yes. And these are people that are pen aficionados? It is a podcast about pens and stationery hosted by Brad Dowdy and Mike Hurley. They have done over 500 podcast episodes about pens. Wow. Yes. They also have a website and they did a review of the Parker Jotter ballpoint pen. Tell me you're going to share the review. You know I am. Yes. Here's what they said about Jim's pen. Quote, the all aluminum body is made in France. It is quite small and slim, so it may not be comfortable for long writing sessions if you
他在开玩笑。他是在开玩笑。好吧，我对这支派克灵动笔产生了一点好奇。它们的零售价大约是12美元一支。我明白了。这就是我的好奇心指引我的地方。有一个播客叫作《笔迷》。真的吗？是的。这些人都是钢笔爱好者吗？这是一个关于钢笔和文具的播客，由布拉德·道迪和迈克·赫利主持。他们已经做了超过500期关于钢笔的播客节目。哇。是的。他们还有一个网站，并且他们对派克灵动笔圆珠笔做过评测。告诉我你会分享这个评测。你知道我会的。是的。这是他们对吉姆那支笔的评价。引述：“全铝笔身产自法国。它相当小巧纤细，所以如果你手比较大，长时间书写可能会觉得不太舒服。”但听听这个。
have large hands. But listen to this. Okay. Listen to this. Okay. Quote, this pen has one of the most satisfying clicks I've ever experienced. It's loud, solid, and has a good amount of resistance. You could drive people crazy with this click and I love it. End quote. I'm sorry. Did we pick the perfect pen for this episode based on that review? Yeah. If you need a pen that you have to click to drive your coworker crazy, head on over and pick up the Parker Jotter. I also love that this podcast has a click rating, like a click meter. That's amazing. I loved every second of that lady. Well, at the very end of this cold open, they are no longer clicking or tapping. They've started blinking at each other. That's right. Did we all catch the wink to camera from
好吧。听听这个。好吧。引述：“这支笔拥有我体验过的最令人满足的点击感之一。声音响亮，扎实，有一定的阻尼感。你可以用这个点击声把别人逼疯，我太喜欢了。”引述结束。不好意思。根据那个评测，我们是不是为这一集挑选了完美的笔？对啊。如果你需要一支通过按压来把同事逼疯的笔，那就去买一支派克灵动笔吧。我也很喜欢这个播客有一个点击评分，就像一个点击测量仪一样。太棒了。女士，我喜欢那里的每一秒钟。好吧，在这个冷开场的最后，他们不再点击或敲击了。他们开始对彼此眨眼睛了。没错。我们都注意到最后吉姆对摄像机眨眼了吗？
Jim at the very end? Of course. It was adorable. It was so cute. Well, we're going to open this episode with Michael and Donna making out in the lobby in front of Hank, played by the lovely Hugh Dane. Yes. I had to walk past them as they made out. What was that morning of shooting like? It was it's just so odd. You know, it's just always weird. You're just going to walk by. They didn't do very many takes that I remember. We got that pretty quickly. I love how Hank is like eating his bowl of cereal. I love everything Hank does. Every choice, everything about Hank is the best. Michael has a talking head here where he says things with Donna are going great on every level. Like he's not used to relationships going
当然。太可爱了。太萌了。好吧，我们要用迈克尔和唐娜在大堂里、在由可爱的休·丹饰演出纳汉克面前亲热的场景来开启这一集。是的。我得从他们亲热的身旁走过去。那天的拍摄早晨是什么样的？太诡异了。你知道，总是感觉很怪。你只是走过去。据我记得，他们没有拍太多次。我们很快就完成了。我喜欢汉克吃麦片粥的样子。我喜欢汉克做的所有事情。每一个选择，关于汉克的每一件事都是最棒的。迈克尔在这里有一段对镜独白，他说他和唐娜在一起的事情在各方面都进展顺利。就像他不习惯感情
as well and he's having trouble focusing on his job. Well, that's going to become clear in this episode. Oh yeah. But you know, one of my favorite things to do is to go to the candy bag alts of talking heads. Here's Michael's alternate talking head for this moment. Things with Donna are going great. I've had good relationships before, but never with another manager. I think that makes all the difference. We co-manage our love. Profits are through the roof. I thought it was so cute. This is reminding me of the one you shared last week. Yes. He kept getting like stuck on this idea that they're both managers. Yes. He's very enamored by that. She gets him in a way maybe no one else has. We're going to go into the conference room now. Michael has called a meeting to ask
进展得这么顺利，而且他现在很难专注于工作。好吧，这将在这一集中变得显而易见。哦，对。但你知道，我最喜欢做的事情之一就是去看那些被删减的备选独白。这是迈克尔此时的备选独白。我和唐娜的事情进展得很顺利。我以前有过美好的恋情，但从来没有和另一个经理谈过。我觉得这大不一样。我们共同管理我们的爱。利润直线上升。我觉得太可爱了。这让我想起了你上周分享的那段。对啊。他一直纠结于“他们俩都是经理”这个概念。是的。他对此着迷不已。她以一种可能没有人有过的方式理解他。现在我们要进入会议室了。迈克尔召集了一个会议，向
everyone for ideas of things that him and Donna can do on the weekends besides have sex. It's just been so much sex. I know. Any ideas? In the shooting draft, everyone quickly threw out suggestions. Here's how it was scripted. Stanley said, I have an idea for your weekend. Let me go back to my desk right now. Andy said, Apple orchards. Oscar said, hiking may be a picnic. Ryan said, learn one skill. Touch one life. Angela said, make soup. You can eat all week. Erin said, popcorn. And then Meredith said, you and Donna should hit the Poconos, heart-shaped jacuzzis. Room enough for three. So that's how it was in the shooting draft. Of course, in the actual scene, there's a variation of that, but I thought that was fun.
大家征求意见，看他和唐娜周末除了做爱之外还可以做点什么。真的是做了太多次爱了。我知道。有什么主意吗？在拍摄初稿中，大家很快提出了各种建议。剧本是这样写的。斯坦利说，我有个周末建议。我现在就回我的办公桌去。安迪说，苹果园。奥斯卡说，远足或者野餐。瑞安说，掌握一项技能。触动一个生命。安吉拉说，做汤。你可以吃一整周。艾伦说，爆米花。然后梅雷迪思说，你和唐娜应该去波科诺山，心形按摩浴缸。三个人绰绰有余。这就是拍摄初稿中的内容。当然，在实际场景中，有所变动，但我觉得那很有趣。
Well, at three minutes and 20 seconds, when Meredith said the jacuzzis have room enough for three, did you see Ryan's reaction? Like he's not even fully on screen, but it made me laugh. He has this expression where he's like, that's not a bad idea. Well, he's been working that angle with Kelly. You know, there was a whole deleted runner after Andy and Erin broke up where Kelly and Ryan hit her up for a threesome. What? Yes. This was a whole runner in secretary's day towards the end of the episode when people are trying to comfort Erin. This is Ryan and Kelly's way of comforting her. You did not share. I didn't share. That is news to me. Well, there you have it. We had a fan catch from Ray H in Jacksonville,
好吧，在三分二十秒的时候，当梅雷迪思说按摩浴缸三个人绰绰有余时，你看到瑞安的反应了吗？就像他甚至没有完全入镜，但把我逗笑了。他露出了那种仿佛在说“这主意不错”的表情。好吧，他一直在凯莉身上施展这套把戏。你知道的，在安迪和艾伦分手后，本来有一整段被删掉的情节，凯莉和瑞安找她去玩三人行。什么？是的。这是在“秘书日”集末的一整段情节，当时大家正试图安慰艾伦。这是瑞安和凯莉安慰她的方式。你之前没分享过。我没分享过。这对我来说是个新闻。好吧，就是这样。我们在杰克逊维尔的雷·H
Florida, who says, Michael says he and Donna went to the PF Changs in Mount Pocono, but there isn't one in Mount Pocono. The nearest PF Changs is in Philadelphia, and it's about an hour and 48 minutes away from Scranton. And now here is my other audio clip about how people say things. Oh, we got a fan catch from Julia T in Orange, California, who says, okay, I have become the rum tracker. All of the Massachusetts people say rum instead of room. John, Steve, Mindy and BJ, and we hear a big old rum from Ryan in his talking head. Here it is. Does she keep her phone locked around you, Michael? Does she watch how much she drinks around you, Michael? Does she leave the room when she takes phone calls?
那里收到了一个粉丝发现，他说，迈克尔说他和唐娜去了波科诺山的PF Changs（华馆），但波科诺山根本没有那家店。最近的PF Changs在费城，距离斯克兰顿大约一个小时四十八分钟车程。现在这是我的另一段关于人们如何发音的音频。哦，我们收到了加利福尼亚州奥兰治的茱莉亚·T发来的粉丝发现，她说，好吧，我成了“rum”追踪者。所有马萨诸塞州的人都把“room”说成“rum”。约翰、史蒂夫、敏迪和BJ，我们在瑞安的独白里听到了一个大大的rum。给你听。她把手机锁起来不让你看吗，迈克尔？她看着你在她身边喝多少酒吗，迈克尔？她接电话时会离开房间吗？
There it is. Did you hear it? Does she leave the room? Rum. That's such a fun catch. I love it. So here's what Ryan is talking about in this conference room meeting. Everyone starts wondering, like, why do you have to go to these weird places to be with your girlfriend? Is she avoiding someone? Is she cheating on you? Kelly is the first person to pick up on this. Kelly says, why did you go to that one? It's so far. And then she's like, Ryan used to do that to me. Yeah. Yeah. Pam tries to be a voice of reason, but by the end of this conference room meeting, Michael is now convinced that Donna is cheating on him. Yeah. It happens so quickly. Oh, yeah. Pam says, Michael, do not let your imagination
就是这样。你听到了吗？她离开房间吗？Rum（姆）。这真是一个有趣的发现。我太喜欢了。所以，瑞安在这次会议上说的是这个。大家开始纳闷，为什么你要去这些奇怪的地方和女朋友在一起？她在躲避什么人吗？她在背着你偷人吗？凯莉是第一个察觉到这一点的人。凯莉说，你为什么要去那一家？太远了。然后她说，瑞安以前对我也这样。对啊。对啊。帕姆试图充当理性的声音，但到这次会议结束时，迈克尔现在确信唐娜在背着他偷人。对啊。这一切发生得太快了。哦，对。帕姆说，迈克尔，别让你的想象力
run out of control. Michael says, well, that's easy for you to say. You have a bad imagination. It's stupid. I live in a fantasy world. Now Michael is going to do something that he should know better. Oh, Michael, Michael, he is going to go in the break room and I titled the scene, whispers in the break room. Anyone want to write a song called whispers in the break room? He goes up to Dwight and gets like in his ear so much so that Dwight's like, what are you doing? And he whispers, I want someone to follow Donna. I want her tailed. I need the name of a good private investigator. And Dwight is going to give Michael his
失控了。迈克尔说，好吧，你倒说得轻松。你的想象力很差。太蠢了。我生活在幻想世界里。现在迈克尔要做一件他本该更懂事的蠢事。哦，迈克尔，迈克尔，他要走进休息室了，我把这个场景命名为“休息室里的耳语”。有人想写一首歌叫《休息室里的耳语》吗？他走到德怀特身边，凑得那么近，以至于德怀特说，你在干嘛？他低声说，我想让人去跟踪唐娜。我想让人尾随她。我需要一个好的私家侦探的名字。而德怀特要把他带有收费标准的
business card with rates. This scene was longer. It was in the shooting draft. And this is how good our scripts come in. As I was reading the shooting draft, I started laughing out loud just because this is so absurd. Listen to this. I have to share it. Dwight goes through his wallet, removes the card. Michael, this is you. Dwight smiles to camera proud. Yes, it is. I used your card guy. Michael, Wade, is he still at the mall? Dwight, he doesn't have a kiosk anymore. He's just working out of the food court. Michael, well, what do you charge? I love that he's like, Wade in the food court, you know, the card guy. I love it that Dwight says that he charges $100 a day plus expenses.
名片给迈克尔。这个场景更长一些。它原本在拍摄初稿里。这就是我们剧本的精彩之处。当我读到拍摄初稿时，我忍不住笑出声来，因为这实在是太荒谬了。听听这段。我必须分享一下。德怀特翻找钱包，掏出名片。迈克尔，这是你。德怀特骄傲地对着镜头微笑。是的，没错。我用了你的名片那个人。迈克尔，韦德，他还在商场吗？德怀特，他没有售货亭了。他现在只在美食广场办公。迈克尔，那他收费多少？我喜欢他说的，在美食广场的韦德，你知道的，那个名片男。我太喜欢德怀特说他收一天100美元加开销了。
Michael says he'll give him 50. Money is no object. I know. Then of course Dwight's going to scoochie across the table. He's on it. Mm-hmm. He's so excited. Well, Jenna, in the episode now, Andy is going to get a call about a printer that caught on fire. Yeah. In the shooting draft, after Andy gets the phone call, rather than turning to Stanley or Gabe, the first person he goes to is Kelly. Oh. Yes. He wants to know if a client has called customer service complaining about faulty printers. Makes sense. We learn a lot about Kelly's attention to detail in this scene and I thought we should hear it. All right. Hey Kelly, have you been getting any calls about the Saver GH400 printers?
迈克尔说他会给50美元。金钱不是问题。我知道。然后当然，德怀特会滑向桌子。他接下了。嗯哼。他太兴奋了。好吧，珍娜，在剧本现在的这一幕里，安迪将接到一个关于打印机着火的电话。是的。在拍摄初稿中，安迪接到电话后，他去找的第一个人不是斯坦利或盖布，而是凯莉。哦。是的。他想知道是否有客户打电话给客服投诉有缺陷的打印机。说得通。我们在这一幕里对凯莉的细心程度有了很多了解，我觉得我们应该听听。好吧。嘿，凯莉，你有没有接到过关于萨博GH400打印机的电话？
Yeah, people hate them. Really? Has anyone said that they like blow up or anything? I can't remember. Can you check? Where? Your records? Okay, I don't keep records per se. Well, like in your files, whenever. Here's Ruby. Those are empty. How do you do your job? You know the bank of file cabinets next to her desk? We see in all the episodes, they're empty. There's nothing in them. I love that he says, how do you do your job? I know. Lady, do you know that I worked as a customer service representative on a complaint line? Oh no. How was that? It was for a major soda company. I won't say which one.
对啊，人们讨厌它们。真的吗？有人说过它们会爆炸什么的吗？我不记得了。你能查查吗？哪里？你的记录？好吧，我没有所谓的记录。嗯，比如在你的档案里，随时。这是鲁比。那些是空的。你怎么工作的？你看到她桌子旁边那排文件柜了吗？我们在所有剧集里都看到它们是空的。里面什么也没有。我喜欢他说，你怎么工作的？我能理解。女士，你知道我曾当过投诉热线的客服代表吗？哦，不。感觉怎么样？那是为一家大型汽水公司服务的。我不会说是哪家。
Can I guess? No, I feel like I shouldn't say which one. Oh, come on. You can guess off air. Oh, you guys. So it was my job to sit. Shmepsie? I'm not going to say. Shmokishmola? I'm not going to say. Okay. The best part of the job was that I got free soda. They had free fountain sodas in the cafeteria. Oh, it was hurt. Located in a very kind of remote area, so you couldn't leave at lunchtime. Your choices were bring something or go to the cafeteria, but you got free soda all day. And you worked the complaint line? I worked the complaint hotline for two weeks as a temp when the person who normally worked there
我可以猜吗？不，我觉得我不应该说到底是哪一个。哦，拜托。你可以在节目外猜。哦，你们这些家伙。所以我的工作就是坐着。Shmepsie？我才不说呢。Shmokishmola？我才不说呢。好吧。这份工作最好的部分就是我有免费苏打水。他们在自助餐厅里有免费的喷泉苏打水。哦，这太伤人了。位于一个非常偏僻的地区，所以你午休时间不能离开。你的选择是带点东西或者去自助餐厅，但你一整天都有免费苏打水喝。你当时负责投诉热线？我当了两周的临时工，负责投诉热线，当时正常做这份工作的人
was on leave. Okay. I had a little bit of training. A little bit of training. Like half an hour. It was like a day, but basically there was a binder. They explained you answer the phone, you listen to the complaint, you take it seriously, you log it, and then you offer to send the person coupons for free soda as a way to apologize for whatever inconvenience they have. And now did they have a script because you know I worked in telemarketing and you usually have a script when someone calls to complain that you follow? There wasn't really a script, but there was a binder that outlined the top complaints and suggested responses. Okay. So for example, the top complaint at the soda company was someone has found a piece of glass
正在休假。好吧。我受了一点点培训。一点点培训。大概半小时吧。感觉像是一天，但基本上有一本文件夹。他们解释说你要接听电话，听取投诉，认真对待，做好记录，然后主动提出给对方寄送免费苏打水的优惠券，作为对他们所受任何不便的道歉。他们当时有台词脚本吗？因为你知道我做过电话销售，通常别人打电话来投诉时，你都会有一份遵循的台词脚本？其实没有什么剧本，但有一个文件夹，里面列出了最常见的投诉和建议的回复。好吧。举个例子，苏打水公司最常见的投诉是有人在苏打水里发现了玻璃
or other object in their soda. Okay. And the response to that was our sodas are canned in a glass-free environment. Most likely the cases were stored next to some kind of broken glass, and then when you opened the soda, it fell in, but there's really no way that we canned it with glass. Okay. But we are so sorry. Right. Even still. We'll send you a coupon. We're going to send you the coupons. And then the second most common was there is a bug in my soda. Okay. Same response. There's no bugs in the soda factory. Right. The third most popular complaint. Okay. Applied only to their diet soda. Okay. And it was there is a gelatinous slug-like creature in my diet soda. When you look in the binder. Is it alive? No. Everyone who called about it was like,
或其他异物。好吧。对此的回复是，我们的苏打水是在无玻璃的环境中罐装的。最有可能的情况是，箱子存放在某种碎玻璃旁边，当你打开苏打水时，它掉了进去，但我们绝对不可能在罐装时混入玻璃。好吧。但我们非常抱歉。对。即便如此。我们会寄给你优惠券。我们会把优惠券寄给你。然后第二常见的投诉是我的苏打水里有虫子。好吧。同样的回复。苏打水厂里没有虫子。对。第三大热门投诉。好吧。仅适用于他们的健怡苏打水。好吧。那就是我的健怡苏打水里有一个像蛞蝓一样的胶状生物。当你翻看文件夹时。它是活的吗？没有。所有打电话来的人都说，
I can't tell what it is. It's like a gelatinous sort of thing in my soda. I don't know what it is. Oh my God. Third most popular complaint. Do you know what the binder said? No. The binder said, we have no explanation for this. Offer coupon. So they knew. They knew in the diet soda there could be a gelatinous thingy. This is a mom defective. When I read that, I was literally sipping their diet soda. Wow. I'll say I continue to drink their diet soda even with this insider info. Have you ever found a gelatinous thingy? I have not. One of the hypotheses was like there's something in the ingredients of the diet soda that if for some reason that soda has gone from very extreme high temperatures to extreme low temperatures and back again can cause it to
我分不清这是什么。它就像我苏打水里的某种胶状物。我不知道这是什么。天哪。第三大热门投诉。你知道文件夹里怎么说的吗？没有。文件夹上写着，我们对此无法解释。提供优惠券。所以他们是知道的。他们知道健怡苏打水里可能会有胶状物。这是一个妈妈侦探。当我读到这行字时，我正字斟句酌地喝着他们的健怡苏打水。哇。我得说，即使有了这些内部消息，我还是继续喝他们的健怡苏打水。你有没有发现过什么胶状物？我没有。其中一个假设是，健怡苏打水成分中的某种东西，如果由于某种原因，苏打水从极高的温度变成了极低的温度，然后又变回来，可能会导致它
like congeal. And that's what that gelatinous thing is. It's just like a congealing of some ingredients. But they don't know. They don't know. Well, this sounds like the soda that would exist in stranger things. Oh my gosh. This season is so scary. Anyway, I really love my job there. It was great. I have a feeling you were better at recording files and documenting things than Kelly. I was. I mean, we had to keep very detailed notes. But you know, one thing I did do. What? Should I admit this? I told my friends and family that if they called me, I could send them coupons for free school. They would work in the system, lady. I did. Well, one of the things that cracked me up about the scene between Kelly and Andy, which would only have like supported his
像凝固了一样。这就是那个胶状物产生的原因。它只是某些成分的凝固。但他们不知道。他们不知道。嗯，这听起来像是《怪奇物语》里才会出现的苏打水。哦天哪。这一季太吓人了。不管怎样，我真的很喜欢在那里的工作。太棒了。我有一种预感，你记录文件和整理资料比凯莉做得更好。我是。我的意思是，我们必须做非常详细的笔记。但你知道，我确实做过一件事。什么？我该承认这一点吗？我告诉我的朋友和家人，如果他们打电话给我，我可以给他们寄免费的学校优惠券。他们在系统里干过活，女士。我真的做了。好吧，凯莉和安迪之间的那个场景最让我捧腹大笑的一点是，这只会支持他的
whole theory, is that Kelly's like, oh yeah, they hate those. Like people are calling in, they hate the printers. They hate them. This is going to become the beginning of an arc, though. Well, in the script and the episode that aired, Andy goes instead to Gabe and says, hey, someone called said the printer caught on fire. And Gabe acts weird. He's very distracted. He's looking for almond butter. Yeah, Gabe really wants a jam sandwich. Yeah, I have a question. Who buys the food for the kitchen? I mean, I have thought this for years. I mean, I just assume people brought in what they wanted and kept it there. But Gabe's question sort of implies that there's someone stocking the kitchen with stuff. It certainly looks like it in this
整个理论，那就是凯莉说，哦，是的，他们讨厌那些。就像人们打电话进来，他们讨厌打印机。他们讨厌它们。不过，这将成为一个故事线的发展开端。好吧，在剧本和播出的剧集中，安迪转而去找加布，说，嘿，有人打电话说打印机着火了。而加布表现得很奇怪。他非常心不在焉。他在找杏仁黄油。是的，加布真的很想要一份果酱三明治。是的，我有个问题。谁为厨房买食物？我的意思是，我多年来一直这么想。我的意思是，我只是假设大家带了他们想要的食物并放在那里。但加布的问题某种程度上暗示了有人在厨房里囤积东西。从这一集来看
episode. If you look at the counter, there's all this variety of tea, so many different kinds of tea. Well, you would notice that. Well, yeah. You love tea. I love tea. Anyway, well, listen, Daryl overhears all this and he says to Andy, did you think that was weird? Gabe's acting weird. He's hiding something. He plants the seed. Well, we're going to find out why and Daryl's talking head. Oh yeah, Daryl's been holding on to something for two years. I guess Andy blamed the warehouse for a late shipment that Andy forgot to process and Daryl almost lost his job and he was mad, but he was like, you know what, I'm going to be patient and I'm going to get my revenge on Andy. We had a fan question from Kim See in Langley,
确实如此。如果你看一下柜台，有各种各样的茶，有那么多不同的茶。嗯，你会注意到这一点的。嗯，是的。你喜欢茶。我喜欢茶。不管怎样，听着，达里尔无意中听到了这一切，他对安迪说，你不觉得这很奇怪吗？加布的表现很奇怪。他在隐藏什么。他种下了怀疑的种子。好吧，我们要找出原因，还有达里尔的独白。哦，对了，达里尔已经憋了两年的气了。我猜安迪曾指责仓库延迟发货，而那是安迪自己忘了处理的，达里尔差点丢了饭碗，他当时很生气，但他心里想，你知道吗，我要有耐心，我要向安迪复仇。我们收到了来自加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省兰利的金·西的粉丝提问，
British Columbia, Canada, who said, how is there a window in Daryl's office? The building has to be bigger than that. There cannot be windows on both sides of the building because the warehouse seems way bigger. Kim, thank you. Thank you for writing in this window. From the time we saw it behind what was Jim's desk, now Daryl's desk has bothered me. It does not fit with the architecture of this building. It is the only window right there. Like if you follow that window over, now you're in the bathrooms. And if you keep following it over, you're in Kelly's nook. Kelly doesn't have a window. No. In fact, Kelly next to her desk has a door. She has an exit door. Similarly, if you track over to accounting, they have a door that we're going to find out later
她问，达里尔的办公室怎么会有一个窗户？这栋楼肯定比那要大。大楼两侧不可能都有窗户，因为仓库看起来大得多。金，谢谢你。谢谢你写信指出这个窗户。从我们看到它在吉姆的桌子后面（现在是达里尔的桌子）开始，它就一直困扰着我。它与这座建筑的建筑风格不符。那是那里唯一的窗户。就像如果你顺着那个窗户往旁边看，你现在就到了洗手间。如果你继续顺着看下去，你就在凯莉的角落里。凯莉没有窗户。没有。事实上，凯莉的桌子旁边有一扇门。她有一扇安全出口门。同样地，如果你转到会计部，他们也有一扇门，我们稍后会发现
goes to a room. Right. Right. Yeah. So if you follow the wall that we're talking about behind Daryl, there's no window. It's the only window. It makes no sense. But I have been like afraid to question it because I'm thinking, well, is that just because I know what's behind there? Like what's behind there are the bathrooms and a working bathrooms that we would use. Yes. And a walkway in the soundstage. You could walk behind that wall to get to like food and stuff. Yeah. So I'm like, I know the building is bigger. But anyway, Kim, I feel validated. Thank you for writing in. Kim, thank you for validating Jenna. I needed it. We're going to start Dwight's undercover work. He's going to find Donna in the parking lot of her gym. That's right.
通往一个房间。对。对。是的。所以如果你顺着我们刚才说的达里尔身后的那堵墙看过去，根本没有窗户。那是唯一的窗户。这完全说不通。但我一直害怕去质疑它，因为我在想，好吧，这只是因为我知道后面有什么吗？就像后面是洗手间，是我们会用的正常工作的洗手间。是的。还有摄影棚里的一条过道。你可以走到那堵墙后面去拿食物之类的东西。是的。所以我心想，我知道这栋楼更大。但不管怎样，金，我觉得我的观点得到了证实。谢谢你写信来。金，谢谢你证实了珍娜的猜想。我正需要这个。我们要开始德 Dwight 的卧底工作了。他要在她健身房的停车场找到唐娜。没错。
This initial meeting in the parking lot was longer. It's in deleted scenes. Listen to how Dwight kicks off his investigation, which relies on him wooing Donna. Listen to how smooth he is. Hey, stranger. Oh, hi. You work for Michael. I work with Michael. Right. White Trout. Donna. Hi. How are you, Donna? Good. How are you? Good. Oh, it's beautiful, isn't it? What? A cloud. What? Which cloud? Cloud of Nats. I could follow a cloud of Nats around for hours. Cloud of Nats. That's how you get them. Well, you know, like you said, Dwight says that the way he's going to find out if Donna is cheating is that he's going to seduce her, bring her to orgasm,
停车场里的这次最初见面时间更长。这在删减片段里。听听德怀特是如何展开他的调查的，这依赖于他对唐娜的追求。听听他有多圆滑。嘿，陌生人。哦，嗨。你为迈克尔工作。我和迈克尔一起工作。对。怀特·特劳特。唐娜。嗨。你好吗，唐娜？很好。你好吗？很好。哦，这天气真好，不是吗？什么？一朵云。什么？哪朵云？一群小飞虫。我可以跟着一群小飞虫走上几个小时。一群小飞虫。这就是你搭讪的方式。嗯，你知道的，正如你所说，德怀特说他要如何查明唐娜是否出轨，那就是他要勾引她，让她达到高潮，
and then break the news to Michael. I have a location breakdown. Let's hear it. Both the interior and exterior of the gym were filmed on location in Recita, California at 360 Health Club, which is now closed. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, there's no ice cream in the kitchen. Oh my God. I can't wait to talk about this. Did he really eat mayonnaise? I'll tell you after the break. Okay. All right, we're back. Michael is glum. He's in the kitchen. Jim and Pam come in, and they find him eating ice cream. They think it's ice cream. There was no ice cream, so he's eating mayonnaise and black olives. We got another fan mail flurry about the mayo
然后把这个消息告诉迈克尔。我有一个拍摄地点分析。说来听听。健身房的内部和外部都是在加利福尼亚州雷西塔的 360 健康俱乐部实地拍摄的，该俱乐部现在已经关闭了。好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，厨房里没有冰淇淋。哦，天哪。我迫不及待地想谈谈这个了。他真的吃蛋黄酱了吗？休息回来后我告诉你。好吧。好了，我们回来了。迈克尔闷闷不乐。他在厨房里。吉姆和帕姆进来，发现他在吃冰淇淋。他们以为那是冰淇淋。根本没有冰淇淋，所以他吃的是蛋黄酱和黑橄榄。我们又收到了一波关于蛋黄酱和橄榄的粉丝来信
and olives. What do we got? Well, Emmie L from Baltimore, Maryland, and many others would like to know what was Steve really eating? Yeah, what was he eating? He was not eating mayo and black olives. I'm pretty sure if I remember correctly, it was yogurt and grapes. He sold it. I don't know why. Washington made me so grossed out. He's going to tell them that he's put Dwight on the case, and Pam and Jim are like, no, Michael, you have to cancel this. Then Michael has my favorite line of this episode. This thing is going to spiral out of a muck. He's trying to use the word Pam used earlier in the conference room, which means out of control. Well, Pam tells Michael that he has a tendency to self-sabotage and torpedo his romantic relationships. Michael
我们收到了什么？嗯，来自马里兰州巴尔的摩的埃米·L以及许多其他人想知道史蒂夫当时到底在吃什么？是的，他到底在吃什么？他当时没有吃蛋黄酱和黑橄榄。我很确定，如果我没记账的话，那是酸奶和葡萄。他演得太逼真了。我不知道为什么。华盛顿让我觉得太恶心了。他要告诉他们，他已经派德怀特去处理这个案子了，而帕姆和吉姆则说，不，迈克尔，你必须取消这个计划。然后迈克尔说出了我在这一集中最喜欢的台词。这件事会陷入一团糟中。他试图使用帕姆之前在会议室里用过的词，意思是失控。好吧，帕姆告诉迈克尔，他有一种自我毁灭和破坏自己的浪漫关系倾向。迈克尔
agrees that he often ruins everything with the loves of his life, which he begins to list. All but Helene. Pam says, Helene? Michael can't seem to recall who this person is, Helene. She's like, my mother? He's like, oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I love Steve's look. Mm-hmm. After he's like, oh, yes, of course, of course. But then he doesn't aside. That's like, I don't know. Not really. Yeah. That's pretty amazing. Well, I guess they get through to him because Michael is going to try to call Dwight and I guess take him off the case. But Dwight's not answering. No, he blocks Michael's call. And he's going to start following Donna around the gym. And I guess this is flirting. It's very strange. Whatever it is, it needs to stop.
同意他经常把生命中挚爱的一切都搞砸，接着他开始列举。除了海伦。帕姆说，海伦？迈克尔似乎想不起这个人是谁了，海伦。她说，我妈妈？他说，哦，对。哦，对。我喜欢史蒂夫的表情。嗯哼。在他说了“哦，是的，当然，当然”之后。但随后他做了一个独白。就像，我不知道。其实并没有。是的。这太神奇了。好吧，我想他们说服了他，因为迈克尔打算打电话给德怀特，并打算把他从这个案子上撤下来。但德怀特没有接听。没有，他屏蔽了迈克尔的电话。并且他开始在健身房里跟踪唐娜。我想这就是调情。这太奇怪了。不管这是什么，都得停下来。
Because Dwight, what are you doing? What is that thing he puts on his head and he's trying to lift? It looked medieval. That's a real thing. I looked it up. No. Yes. It is a thing that is supposed to help strengthen your neck muscles, but Dwight is doing it totally wrong. Like what? The head strappy thing? Yeah. The head strappy thing with a weight on it is a real thing. Now, why do you need super strong neck muscles? I don't know. Maybe it helps you lift other things. You know, like if you're a big lifter, you need a big neck. You need a big neck. But you're not supposed to bend over. You're supposed to stand straight up. So it looked like rain was hurting himself. I was concerned. I did Google something. I got curious. Let me ask you. Okay. Do you know
因为德怀特，你在干什么？他套在头上试图举起来的那个东西是什么？看起来像中世纪的刑具。那是真东西。我查过了。没有。是的。这是一个据说可以帮助锻炼颈部肌肉的东西，但德怀特完全用错了。就像什么？那个绑头的东西？是的，带重量的绑头带是真实存在的。那么，为什么你需要超级强壮的颈部肌肉呢？我不知道。也许它能帮你举起其他东西。你知道，如果你是一个大力士，你需要一个粗壮的脖子。你需要一个粗壮的脖子。但你不能弯腰。你应该直立站着。所以看起来莱恩好像在伤害自己。我很担心。我确实谷歌了一下。我有些好奇。让我问你。好吧。你知道
how much the average human head weighs? Oh gosh. Because I was like, why would you need like, what are we holding up every day? Well, here's the thing. I just sort of have this vague memory from like a science class in school that our heads are really heavy. Like I kind of remember that we have big heads. So what do you think? Sam, do you have a guess? How much does the average human head weigh? I'm going to say 15 pounds. Okay. Angela? Yeah, I was going to say, I don't know. Should I try to lift my own head? How does it feel? I don't know. Like I think 10 to 20 pounds. Okay. On average, a human head weighs 10 to 12 pounds. Oh, I'm giving someone a pretty big bed at 20 pounds. But listen, your head is balanced on just seven vertebrae in your neck and is surrounded by about
人类的头部平均有多重吗？哦天哪。因为我在想，为什么你需要，比如，我们每天都在支撑着什么？好吧，是这样的。我只是从学校的科学课上隐约记得，我们的头真的很重。就像我隐约记得我们有很大的头。所以你觉得呢？萨姆，你猜一下？人类头部的平均重量是多少？我猜是 15 磅。好吧。安吉拉？是的，我本来想说，我不知道。我应该试着抬起我自己的头吗？感觉怎么样？我不知道。我觉得 10 到 20 磅吧。好吧。平均而言，人类头部重 10 到 12 磅。哦，我给 20 磅的猜测留了很大的空间。但听着，你的头仅仅靠脖子上的七块椎骨平衡，周围环绕着大约
20 muscles. And a recent study published in the journal Surgical Technology International shows that if you lean just 15 degrees forward, your head weighs more like 27 pounds. If you lean 30 degrees forward, it weighs about 40 pounds. And when you're hunched over in a position, very common for looking at your phone, your head is putting about a 60 pound strain on your neck. Any wonder you get a neck ache after you've been like on your computer or something? Yes. Our neck muscles were designed to hold our heads when we're straight, not when we're looking at our phones. So everyone right now straighten up. Yeah. Don't be so slouchy over your devices. That's right. I also Googled something this episode. What's that? It's probably a random
20块肌肉。而最近发表在《国际外科技术》杂志上的一项研究表明，如果你向前倾斜仅仅15度，你的头部的重量就会感觉更像是27磅。如果你向前倾斜30度，它重达40磅。而当你驼背时，这对于看手机来说非常常见，你的头部会对你的颈部施加大约60磅的压力。难怪你在电脑前呆了一段时间后会脖子酸痛？是的。我们的颈部肌肉是为了在身体挺直时支撑头部而设计的，而不是在我们看手机时。所以现在每个人都把背挺直。是的。不要在你的设备前驼背。没错。我也在这一集谷歌了一些东西。是什么？这可能是个随机的
time to bring it up. But you know, we do a lot of research. We prep. I always try to find articles written about the show or something specific to the episode. So I Googled the cover up. Thinking maybe one of the first things that would come up would be our show. Oh dear. I got some real random movies and television shows. Okay. With the same name. I'm just going to share my three favorites. There were a lot. Okay. There was a movie in 1949 called cover up starring Barbara Britton, Dennis O'Keefe and William Bendix. The movie poster said it takes more than a kiss to cover up a killing. Oh, I know. I even watched the trailer. I'm like, I kind of want to go watch it. It's on Turner classic movies. Okay. I found an 80s television
提起它的时机。但你知道，我们做了很多研究。我们做了准备。我总是试图寻找有关该节目的文章或与该集具体相关的文章。所以我谷歌了“掩盖”这个词。以为首先跳出来的东西之一可能会是我们的节目。哦，天哪。我搜到了一些非常随机的电影和电视节目。好吧。带有相同的名字。我只想分享我最喜欢的三个。其实有很多。好吧。1949年有一部电影叫《掩盖》，由芭芭拉·布里顿、丹尼斯·奥基夫和威廉·本迪克斯主演。电影海报上写着：掩盖一场谋杀需要的不仅仅是一个吻。哦，我懂。我甚至看了预告片。我想：我有点想去看。它在特纳经典电影频道上。好吧。我发现了一部80年代的电视剧
show called cover up for CBS starring Jennifer O'Neill and John Eric Hexham. The show poster was my favorite. Ready? Yeah. She's the world's sexiest photographer. He's fashion's hottest model. They go where the government can't helping Americans in trouble. What is this show? I know. This is amazing. And I also found a movie from 1991 with Dolph Lundgren and Lewis Gossett Jr. called cover up. The movie poster said if the lies don't kill you, the truth will. Wow. World's sexiest photographer. Fashion's hottest model going where the American government can't. I don't even understand that tagline. I don't. I envision nothing when I hear that. I'll show you the TV poster. Here it is. Undercover, under fire.
由CBS制作，名为《掩盖》，由珍妮弗·奥尼尔和约翰·埃里克·赫克萨姆主演。这部剧的海报是我的最爱。准备好了吗？是的。她是世界上最性感的摄影师。他是时尚界最火的模特。他们深入政府无法触及的地方，帮助陷入困境的美国人。这是什么节目？我知道。这太神奇了。我还发现了一部1991年的电影，由杜夫·龙格尔和小路易斯·格赛特主演，名叫《掩盖》。电影海报上写着：如果谎言杀不死你，真相就会。哇。世界上最性感的摄影师。时尚界最火的模特，深入美国政府无法触及的地方。我甚至听不懂那个宣传语。我不懂。当我听到这个时，我脑海里什么画面都没有。我给你们看电视海报。在这里。卧底，身处战火。
This is incredible. I don't even know how to put words to it. Uh-huh. I'm speechless. Please post this in office ladies pod stories so all can see. Back at the gym, Dwight is working hard. He's getting very sweaty and he will not wipe down his equipment. I have a guest star alert. The woman who would like Dwight to please wipe down his equipment was played by Faye DeWitt. She's been on a ton of television shows including Monk and also Colombo and Mork and Mindy all in the family. Threes company and most recently Crazy X girlfriend. That is quite the resume. I agree. Some amazing shows. Dwight is finally going to leave. He's going to come back to the office and he's going to tell Michael that Donna is not cheating
这太不可思议了。我甚至不知道该用什么词来形容它。嗯哼。我无言以对。请把这个发到办公室女士们的播客故事里，让所有人都能看到。回到健身房，德怀特正在努力锻炼。他流了很多汗，而且他不会擦拭他的器械。我有客串明星警报。希望德怀特擦拭器械的那位女士由费·德威特扮演。她出演过大量电视剧，包括《神探阿蒙》、《神探可伦坡》、《默克和明迪》、《一家子》、以及《三人行》，最近的是《疯狂前女友》。这简历相当丰富。我同意。有一些很棒的节目。德怀特终于要离开了。他要回到办公室，告诉迈克尔，唐娜没有出轨，
but she's furious and she'll be on her way shortly. Also, he signed up for gym membership. Yeah. Michael's going to be billed monthly. I loved Rayne's commitment to his sore legs. I thought it was very accurate. I cannot tell you how many times after I haven't worked out for a long time and I decide that I'm going to work out. I go at it too hard and then I walk like that for about three days. I remember one time I came over to your house. Oh dear. Because you had started trying to do this workout. You had like a what do you call those things? A circuit? You know, you're like, and we're going to do 10 push-ups. Then we're going to do 10 jumping jacks. You had like a thing that you had worked out and I was going to do it with you. Yeah.
但她很生气，很快就会过来。另外，他办了健身房会员卡。是的。迈克尔将按月被扣费。我喜欢莱恩对酸痛腿部的投入。我觉得非常准确。我无法告诉你，在我很久没锻炼后决定开始锻炼的次数有多少。我练得太猛了，然后那样走路大约持续了三天。我记得有一次我去了你家。哦，天哪。因为你开始尝试做这种锻炼。你有一个什么来着，你管那些叫什么？循环训练？你知道的，你就像，我们要10个俯卧撑。然后我们要10个开合跳。你拟定了一个锻炼计划，而我打算和你一起做。是的。
And we don't know why we ever try to work out together. It never goes well. It never goes well. Well, we started doing burpees. Yep. You told me what a burpee was. Maybe I got three done and I was like, I'm going to skip this one. You're like, no, you can't skip. It's a circuit. We got to do this whole thing. I'm like, I'm just going to jump up and down now. I can jump up and down. You're like, it's not the circuit. Anyway, it was really funny. We only did it one time, Jenna. No, we've often started these like fitness things together. We tried yoga. We tried hiking. And recently, again, you were like, lady, we need to do this together. And I thought to myself,
我们不知道为什么我们要一起尝试锻炼。从来没有顺利过。从来没有顺利过。好吧，我们开始做波比跳。是的。你告诉我波比跳是什么。也许我做了三个，我就想：我要跳过这个。你说，不，你不能跳过。这是个循环。我们得做完全套。我说，我只要上下跳跃就好了。我可以上下跳跃。你说，这不是循环。不管怎样，太搞笑了。我们只做了一次，珍娜。不，我们经常一起开始这些健身计划。我们尝试过瑜伽，尝试过徒步。最近，你又说，女士，我们需要一起做这个。我心里想，
why? Why do we need to do it together? We never succeed when we do it together. We are many things. We are best friends. We are business partners. We are lovers of many common interests. Scrapbooking, Target, so many things. Exercise is not our thing. It's not our thing together. It's not our thing together. I do remember though, once I bailed on the burpee and I just said, I'm going to jump up and down, then there was another thing we were supposed to do. And you're like, okay, fine, we can skip that one. We just sort of beat off each other. This is where our partnership ends. Unfortunately, exercise. We are not workout buddies. Well, anyway, I think Michael is moaning on the floor. He's moaning on the floor and Don is going to come in.
为什么？为什么我们非要一起做？我们一起做的时候从来没有成功过。我们有很多身份。我们是最好的朋友。我们是商业伙伴。我们有着许多共同的兴趣爱好。做手账、去塔吉特百货，等等。运动不是我们的强项。我们不适合一起运动。我们真的不适合一起运动。不过我确实记得，有一次我放弃了波比跳，我只是说，我要上下跳跃，然后还有另一项我们该做的运动。然后你说，好吧，好吧，我们可以跳过那个。我们只是互相打发。我们的合伙关系到此为止了。不幸的是，在锻炼方面。我们不是健身搭档。好吧，不管怎样，我想迈克尔正在地板上呻吟。他在地板上呻吟，唐娜要进来了。
He tries to hide from her, but she sees him and she's going to confront him. And it does not go the way I thought it would. Me either. She's somehow charmed by Michael. Yeah. I mean, he does say he just can't believe his luck being with her and that everyone kind of convinced him that, you know, there was something going on. Yeah. And she says, when I say, I like you, I like you, let's go away to Vero Beach. And Michael says, is that on the water? That's pretty amazing. Meanwhile, Andy is going to go into Darrell's office. Did anyone else catch the giant bass fish mounted on Darrell's wall at 13 minutes, two seconds? Yes, I did, lady. Has that always been there? Was that there when it was Jim's office? I don't know. How did we miss
他试图躲开她，但她看到了他，并要去找他当面对质。结果和我想象的不一样。我也是。她不知怎么地被迈克尔迷住了。是的。我的意思是，他确实说他简直不敢相信能和她在一起是多么幸运，而且每个人都让他确信，你知道的，他们之间有点什么。是的。她说，我说我喜欢你，我就是喜欢你，我们去维罗海滩度假吧。迈克尔说，那是在水边吗？这太神奇了。与此同时，安迪要走进达里尔的办公室。有没有人注意到在13分02秒时，达里尔墙上挂着的那条巨大的鲈鱼标本？是的，我注意到了，女士。那个一直都在那儿吗？当这里是吉姆的办公室时，它在那儿吗？我不知道。我们怎么会错过
that big bass? I don't know. Darrell tells Andy that he overheard Gabe saying something about eliminating Andy because he's been a problem. Andy starts to spiral. Yeah. Meanwhile, in the break room, we had one of my favorite Kelly moments ever where she lists off every store and every mall. She knows every store anywhere. Yeah. Because Donna has on heart earrings and Kelly wants to know where she got them. And Donna is hedging. I loved it so much. I pulled an audio clip. Oh, hey, I love your earrings. Thank you. Did Michael get them for you? No, I bought them myself. Where? Steamtown Mall. Clairs, dales, rickies, earrings, earrings, fancy girl, bottom cat. Where? You know, I actually got them in Philadelphia and I'm all down there.
那条大鲈鱼？我不知道。达里尔告诉安迪，他无意中听到加布说要除掉安迪，因为他一直是个麻烦。安迪开始崩溃了。是的。与此同时，在休息室里，我们迎来了我最喜欢的凯莉的高光时刻之一，她列出了每一个商场的每一家商店。她知道任何地方的每一家商店。是的。因为唐娜戴着心形耳环，凯莉想知道她是在哪儿买的。而唐娜在敷衍。我太喜欢了。我截取了一段音频。哦，嘿，我喜欢你的耳环。谢谢。是迈克尔买给你的吗？不，我自己买的。在哪儿？蒸汽城购物中心。克莱尔斯、戴尔斯、里基斯、耳环、耳环、花哨女孩、底层猫。在哪儿？你知道，我其实是在费城的购物中心买的。
Franklin Mills, King of Prussia, Springfield, Governor's Place. Franklin Mills. Mm-hmm. Uh-huh. Pam clocks it right away. Also, did you notice what Meredith is reading through this whole scene? What? Men's health. I did not notice. Yeah. Well, Pam can't let this heart jewelry thing go. She's going to have another talking head with Jim, where she says women don't buy heart-shaped jewelry for themselves. A man definitely bought that for her. That's right. And Jim says, do you like heart-shaped jewelry? And she's like, no. I mean, except for this necklace that you gave me, which I love. She caught herself pretty quickly. Creed is going to pass Andy and he's going to do like the finger across the throat.
富兰克林米尔斯、普鲁士国王、斯普林菲尔德、州长广场。富兰克林米尔斯。嗯哼。呃-huh。帕姆立刻注意到了这一点。还有，你注意到梅雷迪思在这整场戏里在看什么吗？什么？《男士健康》。我没有注意到。是的。好吧，帕姆对这件心形首饰的事放不下。她将和吉姆进行另一场独白，她说女人不会为自己买心形首饰。这绝对是男人买给她的。没错。吉姆说，你喜欢心形首饰吗？她说，不。我的意思是，除了你送我的这条项链，我超爱。她反应挺快，自己圆回来了。克里德走过安迪身边，做了一个抹脖子的动作。
Yeah, gesture. This will make Andy spiral even more because Creed is head of quality assurance. Maybe he's wrapped up in this. Creed has a talking head where he says, so there I am, minding my own business. And Darnell offers me three bucks. All I got to do is walk by Andy and go like this. Darnell's a chump. I would have done it for anything. I've done a lot more for a lot less. I noticed the recurring $3. Remember? Mm-hmm. Didn't Creed have a $3 bill earlier? Yes. With, I thought it was Brad Pitt. Turns out it was George W. Bush. Well, there is a candy bag alt for the second part of Creed's talking head. Uh-huh. Instead of saying I would have done it for anything, I've done a lot more for a lot less. Creed's alt that
是的，手势。这会让安迪更加崩溃，因为克里德是质量保证主管。也许他也牵涉其中。克里德有一段独白，他说，所以当时我在那儿，管我自己的事。达内尔给了我三块钱。我只需要从安迪身边走过去，然后像这样。达内尔是个笨蛋。我为了什么都愿意干。我为了更少的东西做过更多的事。我注意到了那个反复出现的三美元梗。记得吗？嗯哼。克里德之前不是有一张三美元钞票吗？是的。上面印着，我以为是布拉德·皮特。结果是乔治·W·布什。好吧，在克里德那段独白的第二部分，有一个废弃的糖果包镜头。嗯哼。他没有说“我为了什么都愿意干，我为了更少的东西做过更多的事”，克里德拍了但被剪掉的镜头
they did shoot, it was a must shoot was, can you believe it? I thought this was going to be a terrible week, what with my mom dying, but life surprises you sometimes. Oh my God. I know. Oh, Creed. Well, this Andy storyline would have continued with this scene between Aaron and Andy in the kitchen. Really? Yeah. We haven't seen anything between Aaron and Andy since their breakup. Yes. But they had a whole scene. We talked about it briefly last week and I said I would share. In the shooting draft, Andy enters the kitchen and walks over to Aaron who is seated at the table. She looks up and smiles. He looks behind him and takes a seat at the table. Andy says, I think I've uncovered something pretty big and if anything happens to me, I want you to read this
那是必拍镜头，上面写着：你能相信吗？我以为这会是糟糕的一周，我妈妈去世了，但生活有时会给你带来惊喜。天哪。我知道。哦，克里德。好吧，这条安迪的故事线本应通过厨房里艾琳和安迪之间的这场戏继续发展。真的吗？是的。自从他们分手后，我们就再没见过艾琳和安迪之间有什么互动了。是的。但他们有一整场戏。我们上周简短地讨论过，我说过我会分享。在拍摄剧本中，安迪进入厨房，走向坐在桌旁的艾琳。她抬头笑了笑。他看了看身后，在桌旁坐下。安迪说，我想我发现了一件相当大的事，如果我出了什么事，我想让你读这封信。
letter. It has every feeling I've ever felt about you. Everything I've ever wanted to say to you, but didn't have the courage. I put it all in this letter. He slides it to her. He then goes on to say, however, and I can't be clearer on this point. If nothing happens to me, absolutely do not under any circumstances read this letter. And Aaron says, okay. Oh my gosh. That is crazy. Well, now there's going to be a big break in the case of is Donna cheating and is a mom detective. She sure is. Turns out she and Donna have a friend of a friend in common on Facebook and she was able to see some of Donna's posts. Now, first of all, obviously Michael doesn't follow Donna on Facebook. No, because there are pictures of her canoodling with another man.
这里面有我对你产生过的所有感觉。所有我想对你说但没有勇气说的话。我都写在这封信里了。他把它推给她。接着他说，然而，关于这一点我再怎么强调也不为过。如果我什么事都没有，绝对、在任何情况下都不要读这封信。艾琳说，好的。哦，天哪。这太疯狂了。好了，现在关于“唐娜是否出轨以及妈妈侦探”的案子将迎来一个重大突破。她当然是的。原来她和唐娜在脸书上有共同的朋友的朋友，她能够看到唐娜的一些帖子。首先，很显然迈克尔没有在脸书上关注唐娜。没有，因为上面有她和另一个男人亲昵的照片。
There's multiple pictures. Yeah. So we're going to come to find out in this episode that Donna is married and the person she's kissing in these photos is her husband. Yeah. And this character of Donna's husband is going to show up next week. Spoiler alert. Randy told me that the actor who is going to play Donna's husband named Shane had been hired for the following week. His name was Larkin Campbell. So they contacted Allison Jones and Allison gave them a general description of Larkin and they cast a background artist to stand in and be a photo double so that they could take the pictures for this episode for Pam to have as a prop. These photos were shot by Michael Gallenberg on a green screen over on the warehouse stage and Henry Sane built the
有很多照片。是的。所以我们将在这一集中发现，唐娜已婚，她在这些照片中亲吻的人是她的丈夫。是的。而唐娜丈夫这个角色将在下周出现。剧透警告。兰迪告诉我，将扮演唐娜丈夫的演员名叫沙恩，他已经为接下来的一周签约了。他的名字叫拉金·坎贝尔。所以他们联系了艾莉森·琼斯，艾莉森给他们提供了拉金的外貌描述，他们选定了一名群众演员来充当替身，这样他们就可以为这一集拍摄照片，让帕姆拿着作为道具。这些照片是由迈克尔·盖伦伯格在仓库舞台上的绿幕前拍摄的，亨利·塞恩制作了
Photoshop composite and the Facebook printouts that Pam holds up. A lot went into these printouts. Yeah. Including Amy Pete's having to kiss a random fella for these pictures. Oh, yeah. Right? Yeah. These are details you don't think about. Also, I just want to say, Pam also shows a photo of Cece. Mm-hmm. That was a photo of my real niece Cece. Oh, it's such a cute picture. I know. It's at 15 minutes and 35 seconds. It's so crazy cute. Well, Pam is going to take these pictures in a folder and march into Michael's office where he is sitting with Donna. It looks like they're looking at places to stay in Varro Beach. Mm-hmm. And this was a bit of a stretch for me that Pam would hand Michael these pictures when he is seated next to Donna. And Donna,
Photoshop 合成图以及帕姆拿着的脸书打印件。这些打印件花了很多心思。是的。包括艾米·皮茨不得不为了这些照片去吻一个随机的家伙。哦，对。对吧？是的。这些是你不会想到的细节。另外，我只想说，帕姆还展示了一张西西的照片。嗯哼。那是我的真实侄女西西的照片。哦，这是一张多么可爱的照片。我知道。在 15 分钟 35 秒处。太疯狂可爱了。好吧，帕姆拿着这些照片，把它们放在一个文件夹里，气势汹汹地走进迈克尔的办公室，他和唐娜正坐在那里。看起来他们正在寻找维罗海滩的住宿地点。嗯哼。对于帕姆在唐娜坐在旁边时将这些照片递给迈克尔，这对我来说有点牵强。而唐娜，
what, doesn't even glance over? She doesn't even see what he's looking at? Pam tries to get Michael out of the room. She says, Michael, I need to discuss my sex life with you. I know. She's desperate to get him out of that room. I mean, what else is she supposed to say? She makes up multiple reasons for him to leave the room with her, and he will not. My issue is not with Pam. My issue is, how is it that Donna doesn't just glance over and see what Michael is looking at? Because she's too invested in finding a good vacation spot. Okay. I absolutely loved filming this scene. I had so much fun with Steve, so much of that dialogue. And back and forth, we kind of found on the day. Mm-hmm. I figured you did. It looks like you guys were having fun.
怎么连看都不看一眼？她甚至没看到他在看什么吗？帕姆试图把迈克尔弄出房间。她说，迈克尔，我需要跟你讨论我的性生活。我知道。她急于把迈克尔弄出那个房间。我的意思是，她还能说什么？她编造了多种理由让他和她一起离开房间，但他就是不走。我的问题不在于帕姆。我的问题是，为什么唐娜不看一眼迈克尔在看什么呢？因为她太专注于寻找一个好的度假地点了。好吧。我非常喜欢拍摄这场戏。我和史蒂夫合作得非常开心，很多台词。以及我们当场碰撞出的来回对话。嗯哼。我想你也是。看起来你们玩得很开心。
I also want to point out at 16 minutes, in the background, Phyllis is not at her desk. John is at his desk, and Creed is standing at Dwight's desk. The reason for this was that Phyllis could not be in the background that day, and Rain, who was directing, could not be in the background. So in order to fill out that area, he had Creed step forward and stand at Dwight's desk. Michael and Pam are outside Advanced Refrigeration, where Michael is flipping out. Yeah. He's freaking out with this new information. Yeah. Michael does not know what to do with this information. He walks Donna to her car, and he's kind of trying to trick her by making plans for the weekend but then changing them.
我还想指出，在第16分钟，在背景中，菲利斯不在她的座位上。约翰在他的座位上，克里德站在德怀特的桌子旁。原因那天菲利斯无法出现在背景中，而作为导演的莱恩也无法出现在背景中。所以为了填满那个区域，他让克里德走上前去，站在德怀特的桌子旁。迈克尔和帕姆在高级制冷公司外面，迈克尔在那里崩溃了。是的。面对这个新消息，他吓坏了。是的。迈克尔不知道该如何处理这个消息。他把唐娜送到她的车旁，他试图通过制定周末计划然后又更改来捉弄她。
Yeah, to Tuesday, and then she's like, oh, but I can't do Tuesday. Finally, Michael tells Donna he knows that she's cheating on him because Pam told him. And then he looks up, and Jenna, you like spring, like talk about this athletic move, where you like lunge and dive forward onto the ground. We got a fan question from Kelsey B. in North Carolina, who said, I love when Pam hits the floor so that Donna doesn't see her. Was this scripted because it's absolutely hilarious? Yes. That moment was scripted. In the script, it says, Pam hits the floor, and it was so fun to shoot. We kept laughing. I just kept trying to fling
是的，改成周二，然后她说，哦，但我周二不行。最后，迈克尔告诉唐娜他知道她背叛了他，因为帕姆告诉他的。然后他抬起头，珍娜，你喜欢像，谈谈这个运动动作，你像弓步一样向前俯冲倒在地上。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州吉尔斯·B的粉丝提问，她说，我喜欢帕姆倒在地上以防唐娜看到她的那一幕。这是按剧本演的吗，因为绝对太搞笑了？是的。那一刻是按剧本演的。剧本里写着，帕姆倒在地上，拍这一幕太有趣了。我们一直在笑。每次我们笑场时，我都试图以最荒谬的方式把自己甩到地上。我们在那个时刻玩得很开心。但这就是迈克尔发现自己才是她出轨对象的时候。
myself on the floor in the most ridiculous way every time we were cracking up. We had a lot of fun with that moment. But this is when Michael is going to find out that he is the person she's cheating with. Yeah, he's the other guy. And next week, we're going to learn what Michael's feelings are about that. About being the other fella? Yeah. At 18 minutes, four seconds, Gabe is going to tell Andy that they have investigated all of the instances of faulty printers. In every case, it was user error. He's going to really creepily offer him a $5 Dunkin' Donuts gift card. Yeah, like as a thank you for bringing this to our attention. Andy seems happy. And then Daryl shakes him off like, nope, something's still going on. That's right. He manages to convince Andy
是的，他是第三者。下周，我们将了解迈克尔对此的感受。关于做另一个家伙？是的。在18分04秒，加布告诉安迪，他们已经调查了所有发生故障的打印机情况。在每种情况下，都是用户操作失误。他非常毛骨悚然地送给安迪一张5美元的唐恩都乐礼品卡。是的，就像是感谢你把这件事提出来一样。安迪看起来很高兴。然后达里尔把他叫住，不，事情还在继续。没错。他设法说服安迪
to film himself using one of these printers. They're down in the defunct Michael Scott paper company room. Remember, Michael rented that space forever. It's there. Yeah, he's going to have it for a while. In the shooting draft, the scene was described like this. Interior Michael Scott paper company. It barely resembles the old MSPC. There's some garbage in the corner and a few motivational posters on the wall. A Sabre printer is set up on a ledge, and it is printing many copies. Daryl videotapes Andy with the printer in the background, and the printer is printing. Well, Randy told me that they didn't think we were ever going to use that space again, and they had converted it back to being a post production store room. Oh my gosh,
把自己使用其中一台打印机的过程录下来。他们在废弃的迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司房间里。记住，迈克尔永远租下了那个空间。它还在。是的，他要用上一阵子。在拍摄剧本中，这个场景是这样描述的：内景。迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。它几乎不像以前的 MSPC 了。角落里有一些垃圾，墙上贴着几张励志海报。台阶上架设了一台 Sabre 打印机，它正在打印许多份文件。达里尔用摄像机拍摄安迪，背景是打印机，打印机正在打印。嗯，兰迪告诉我，他们原以为我们再也不会使用那个空间了，他们把它改回了后期制作储藏室。哦，天哪，
they had to move everything out. They did. They had to take everything back out again. He said luckily they had left the fakey shower and the kind of stained walls, but he said our set deck team headed by Steve Rothstein and the lead man Jim McDermott had to totally recover that space, basically. Well, Andy is putting on the presentation of this printer. Daryl keeps making him talk in a higher voice. Yes. And now he's talking really high, and guess what starts happening? The printer starts smoking and catches on fire. Daryl is genuinely shocked. Randy told me that the printer in the scene was rigged by Ron Nary, our head of special effects, and our on set effects person, Mike Thompson, was there to kind of make it all
他们不得不把所有东西都搬出去。他们确实搬了。他们不得不把所有的东西再次搬出去。他说幸运的是他们留下了那个假淋浴间和有些污渍的墙壁，但他指出我们的布景道具团队由史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦带领，主道具师吉姆·麦克德莫特不得不彻底恢复那个空间，基本上是这样。好吧，安迪正在对这台打印机进行演示。达里尔一直让他用更高的声音说话。是的。现在他说话的声音真的很高，你猜开始发生什么了？打印机开始冒烟并着火了。达里尔真的惊呆了。兰迪告诉我，场景中的打印机是由我们的特效主管罗恩·内里操纵的，我们的现场特效人员迈克尔·汤普森也在现场，以确保一切
work. First, they had to hide a remote controlled electronic smoke generator, which produced the safe smoke, which is very similar to what we use in that fire drill, the opening of stress relief. And then the sparks were created using squibs, which were similar to what we use to make Andy's battery spark in mafia. And then finally, he told me that Craig used a real CO2 fire extinguisher. That looked real. I thought so too. But did you notice the fakie labels on the printer that say saber? If you look close, there's two. Fakie label. This moment is going to sober up Daryl pretty quickly. That's right. He's going to have a talking head where he says, I don't want to prank anymore. Things get real. It's not funny. I'm just going to be good.
正常运作。首先，他们不得不隐藏一个远程控制的电子烟雾发生器，它产生了安全烟雾，这非常类似于我们在压力缓解开头的那个消防演习中使用的烟雾。然后火花是通过使用微型爆破装置产生的，类似于我们用来让安迪在黑手党中电池产生火花的装置。最后，他告诉我克雷格使用了一个真正的二氧化碳灭火器。看起来很真实。我也这么觉得。但你注意到打印机上写着“sabre”的假标签了吗？如果你仔细看，有两个。假标签。这一刻让达里尔很快清醒过来。没错。他会有一段独白，他说，我再也不想恶作剧了。事情变得真实了。这不好笑。我要做一个好人。
Stay in my room. Go to church. Try to do one nice thing per day. I do not want to prank anymore. No more pranks. I don't like pranks myself. We've talked about this. I hate prank. I know. We hate pranks. We're on board with Daryl. Daryl, stay away from the pranking. This episode ends with Dwight back at the gym. He has aggressively taken over a spin class. Guess our alert. The spin instructor was played by David Mait and according to IMDB, he played professional ice hockey in Europe. Wow. I know. When we reached out to Rain, he said he absolutely loved doing the scene and he said he thinks the writers had for a while this idea that Dwight would take over an exercise class. It is pretty funny. I mean, talk about a class that would
呆在我的房间里。去教堂。每天尝试做一件好事。我再也不想搞恶作剧了。再也没有恶作剧了。我自己也不喜欢恶作剧。我们谈过这个。我讨厌恶作剧。我知道。我们讨厌恶作剧。我们和达里尔统一战线。达里尔，离恶作剧远点。这一集的结尾是德怀特回到健身房。他强行接管了一场动感单车课。客串明星警报。动感单车教练由大卫·梅特扮演，根据IMDB的数据，他曾在欧洲打过职业冰球。哇。我知道。当我们联系莱恩时，他说他绝对喜欢拍摄这一幕，并且他认为编剧们有这样一个想法有一段时间了，那就是德怀特会接管一个健身班。这真的很有趣。我的意思是，说到一个能
make sure you worked out would be Dwight yelling at you on a spin bicycle. It's so true. Finally, we got a fan question from Sasha L from McAllen, Texas who said, I noticed that this episode was dedicated to Larry Einhorn. Who is that? Well, Sasha, that was Randall Einhorn's father. His father had passed away suddenly while we were in post-production on this episode and it was Greg Daniel's idea to add him to the end credits. Yeah. Well, there you have it, guys. That's the cover up. That's the cover up. Next week is the chump and we are winding down season six. Only two more episodes to go. Wow. I know. And then we're in Steve's final season. Oh my gosh. That's gonna be emotional. It is and Steve has got to come on. He said he would come on for goodbye, Michael.
确保你得到锻炼的班级，那就是德怀特在动感单车上对你大喊大叫。确实如此。最后，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州麦卡伦的萨沙·L的粉丝提问，她说，我注意到这一集是献给拉里·伊恩霍恩的。那是谁？嗯，萨沙，那是兰德尔·伊恩霍恩的父亲。他的父亲在我们制作这一集的后期时突然去世了，格雷格·丹尼尔斯提出了把他加到片尾字幕中的想法。好吧，这就是全部内容了，伙计们。这就是《掩盖》。这就是《掩盖》。下周是《笨蛋》，我们将迎来第六季的尾声。只剩最后两集了。哇。我知道。然后我们就进入史蒂夫的最后一季了。哦，天哪。那将会很感人。确实如此，史蒂夫一定要来。他说过他会来参加“再见，迈克尔”。
When we reached out to him a long time ago to be on the podcast, he said, guys, can I come on for goodbye, Michael and just talk about it all? Oh my gosh. If Steve is able to come in studio, I will cry. I will cry. There's gonna be a lot of crying happening in season seven. Season seven. Buckle in. All right. Well, you guys, thank you so much for listening. Thank you to Rainn Wilson for sending us an audio clip. Thank you to Randy Cordray and we just hope you guys have a great week. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate
很久以前，当我们邀请他来上播客时，他说，伙计们，我能来聊聊‘再见，迈克尔’然后把所有事情都谈一谈吗？天哪。如果史蒂夫能来到录音室，我会哭的。我会哭的。第七季里会有很多哭戏。第七季。系好安全带。好了，非常感谢大家收听。感谢雷恩·威尔逊发来的音频剪辑。感谢兰迪·科德雷，我们希望大家度过美好的一周。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副
producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 office。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。